most people even in this room haven't  really synthesized their strategies on  the fact that the internet is different  from the blockchain  and if you haven't done that then you  don't even understand the functionality  of the blockchain and how do I know this  because it's what happened with people  in The Logical real world were unable to  do with the internet  when I was pitching wine library.com in  1996 literally everybody who I talked to  said to me who would ever go on the  internet to buy a bottle of wine I can  go to the store and get it and my  response was everyone  and so what what and that blew people's  [ __ ] mind in 1996 right because we  still had people and you all know this  almost every single person on this calls  parents  was scared to put a credit card into a  computer in 1999.  and so what we're seeing now with  people's fear like most people in this  room that [ __ ] on nfts if they do don't  realize that they've become their  parents